It's not like a real point. He's just
exploring prop logic more. He doesn't
even exploring prop logic more. And
that's why he stomped me on multiple
points in the conversation. Why have an
incoherent mess? Dude, it's such cope,
man. It's such cope. A little bit of uh,
you know, psychology came out there, I
fear. Does he think about his content
past just being like a
reactive drone? No, you did. You did not
say kind of. You did not. Let's run that
back. You wanted to be in this debate.
You wanted to go hard. You wanted to
stand on it. You wanted to say, "Oh
yeah. Oh yeah." So Substance, great
Twitter account, made this clip. Vonabox
responds to chatters who point out the
blatant misrepresentation in Ethan
Klein's latest response in his copyright
lawsuit, such as the cited R/H3 snark
mod not actually being a mod and Ethan
having no evidence/proof of collusion
with denims.
So, what does Lonabox have to say about
the latest filings in the Ethan lawsuit?
Let's hear it. The Snark mod directly
communicated with Denims on their intent
to create a market replacement, Absolute
Cinema.
On the 21st of January 2025, the H3
Snark mod with the Discord username
Dartis sent Denims a direct message on
Discord stating, "Can you advertise on
the H3 Snark before or when the content
puke?
i.e. the nuke is released. I try to time
I try time time to gather people there
to join your stream, but we need you for
this one so we don't boost Ethan's
release. On January 28th, 2025, Darto
was sent a screenshot on Denim's Discord
server from H3 Stark. Then stated,
remember to just wait a bit and watch it
on Denim Twitch stream or other
creators. We must not feed Ethan's
engagement. [laughter]
Is there single evidence this guy is a
mod? never said the guy was a mod. Ethan
didn't provide any evidence he is. Also,
Dennis didn't respond to the DM. How is
it colluding? Didn't say it was
colluding. You can challenge me in
anything I've actually said if you want
rather than attacking things I haven't
said, but okay. That's what Ethan said
in the filing. Did he? Oh, I don't know
then.
Oh, I don't know. Oh, Ethan said
something that has no evidence for it.
There might be just like complete bunk.
Oh, I don't know. I don't know.
>> You agreed. The thing that I was
>> Yeah, he got very defensive as a
>> Oh, here a mod. Yeah, I don't know if
this person's a mod.
The thing I was more baffled by was the
[__] on the nose
quality of these statements.
>> So, why would that matter if Denims
didn't reply and it's not a moderator?
So, what why does that statement matter?
Like you're saying, oh, on the nose
quality statement. Yeah, some [__]
said they really don't want Ethan to get
views.
Who cares? Why is that? The on the nose
quality of that statement is not
significant if it isn't relevant to
anyone that we actually care about in
the lawsuit.
The [__] on the nose
quality of these statements,
but okay.
And then I said, I haven't read the
court cases, so I'll probably read all
of them at some point. Is that okay?
What What does it change that this
person's not a mod?
>> Like the whole [__] thing, dude. Like
the whole [__] thing.
[laughter]
It changes like the whole [__] thing,
dude.
He's trying to sue the moderators of H3
Snug. That's he wants to sue them for
contributo copyright infringement.
That's his goal. If this isn't a mod
who's saying this, then it massively
loses credibility. It's like totally is
like borderline irrelevant.
So, let's have a look. Am I heating off?
Okay,
we have big drama. So much of it. Where
do [snorts] we even start?
>> So, let's say this in full context.
communicated with Denims on their intent
to create a market replacement, Absolute
Cinema.
On the 21st of January 2025, the H3
Snark mod with the Discord username
Darttois sent Denims a direct message on
Discord stating, "Can you advertise on
the H3 Snark before or when the content
puke,
i.e. the nuke is released? I try to time
I try to time to gather people there to
join your stream, but we need you for
this one so we don't boost Ethan's
release.
On January 28th, 2025, Darto was sent a
screenshot on Denim's Discord server
from H3 Stark. Then stated, remember to
just wait a bit and watch it on Denim
Twitch stream or other creators. We must
not feed Ethan's engagement, [laughter]
dude.
It's so [__] sad. Darth
>> is respond.
>> Jewish man who wants to control the net
and world get a giant octopus on his
wall.
>> Tag noticing.
>> Thank you for the 333. Thank you.
>> To a user asking whether denims should
watch a host a watch party with I hope
we do. I'm marketing like crazy for it.
Dartis clarified with promoting sorry
snark mostly. Hopefully the content puke
will be the nail in Ethan's coffin, but
the amount of hate watch could help him
survive a couple of quarters if I'll
watch it. This shows the H3 Snark mods
lied to this court about their intent to
siphon views away from TEI.
I mean, yeah, maybe I'll read these full
filings one day and actually see because
I feel like uh the the real reasoning
and the real timeline of these suits has
maybe gotten a bit lost.
>> Uhhuh. So,
I might have to check it out. Might have
to go through the whole one. I've
actually taken a slight interest in it
now. Mostly because everyone else cares
so much about it. I just don't I don't
understand. I don't understand [__]
like like why people are up in arms
about this being a problem like to to do
this when it's so [__] ob it's so
>> like he's so [__] man. He becomes
so [__] looking at this topic. It's
baffling. He's like, "Why is anyone
upset about this? Look, the moderator is
literally saying they want to steal
views right here. You're a [__]
idiot, bro. You're truly [__] stupid.
Like, there's no there's not a good
excuse for this.
>> Beyond the pale, like like even if you
think that the the whatever [__]
arbitrary social rules that we've set
for React streaming where basically
every React streamer to some degree or
another is a legal in legal terms like a
sort of content thief. But obviously we
vary to how much we transform and how
much of an effort we make. And then
there's also the fact that like it al
because it's civil cases it would matter
with what the reacti the reactee
believes as well because um if you're
doing an adversarial react some people
complain that someone didn't watch the
full video and maybe if they did it
would be better. So like
what happens there right? Like you've
got someone who's like oh you didn't
even watch the full video but versus
like steal. So that's how I feel anyway
and that's how I think a lot of people
do. If someone wanted to react to
something that I did like like a piece
like a 20 30 50 minute piece then I'd
prefer that they reacted to the whole
thing to see the whole argument rather
than just cherry picking a few facts
>> because I don't trust people to choose
like to I don't trust
>> you don't get to decide which parts of
my argument are important to hear
>> ten to actually summarize my position in
a fair way. Generally I don't trust
people to do that. So, I'd rather just
watch the whole thing and let the
audience
see what's going on and then that way
they cannot probably also concede the
things where they they probably agree
with me, right? Um,
but even if you believe all that and
like the standards that we've set like
surely this just still even the XQC
stuff like this still goes beyond like
it's
>> Yeah, this goes so far beyond, doesn't
it? When some random Discord user says
they don't want
people to watch one thing and they want
them to watch you instead. Whoa, this is
so crazy. Whoa, this is so [__]
crazy, guys. Whoa, this is so [__]
Doesn't it go so far beyond? Doesn't
this go so far beyond?
>> High level research. Thank you, Locks.
>> It goes beyond
>> I don't know. I'm
>> not motivated reasoning, guys. not
motivated to get arrested for smoking
weed, but if you're going to go and
[__]
spliff up in front of a [__] police
station,
>> back to another [__] analogy that
doesn't deal with any of the specifics
of a case, ignoring the fact that he's
reading a [__] lie and building
assumptions off of it.
>> As a pig screaming, "Fuck the popo."
>> It's like classic liner box H3 segment.
Classic Lab Box H3 segment.
>> [__] you. Then I'm probably not going to
care. the most terrible reasoning,
terrible engagement you ever
>> basic social conditioning as a basic
setting a basic example for the social
contract. like you probably shouldn't
behave with that level of impunity
towards [laughter]
>> but anyway
>> guys maybe if I just do 200 more
analogies where I deliberately avoid
talking about any of the specifics of
this case
maybe it'll start making sense and he
full sips full sips because he knows
he's just done a ret another [__]
analogy to generalize and avoid making
any specific statements about this case
thank you loin box thank you another
great you know H3 will be really proud
of
Ethan's Ethan's looking there and this
floor's cleaner than he's ever seen it.
Floor's cleaner than he's ever seen it.
Okay. Certainly no dog [__] there after
loaner box finished sweeping
all in a day's work.
Whatever. Have you considered misogyny?
Yes. And I believe
I can concede that I haven't done enough
of it. Where is this?
knowing the group he lurks in. Pisco has
got annoying about it and I'm starting
to doubt his intentions knowing the
group he lurks in. Um, assume good faith
until you're proven otherwise. Again,
Ethan puts his foot in his mouth or even
beyond that just says [__] like
shitty and does shitty things like quite
a lot. Like he's not like a he is far
from a perfect actor, right? Um,
I think a better explanation for Pisco's
little uh like like hanging on to this
issue is one, it it obviously sounds
like he's been um for one, he definitely
sounds like he's been exploring like
prop logic more often um and wants to
play with that like a new toy. But no,
more more seriously,
>> it's like such [__] cope, man.
The prop prop logic because you because
he asks, "Are you saying possible,
plausible, or likely?" It's such co out
these like how can you do this? Okay,
you are loner box. You are a the Destiny
fan. You are like uh you know Robin, you
know. You're like Robin. You're like the
the fan. You've been around for so long.
You've been debating for so long. You've
you've been a you've been
fighting with the Hassan retards for so
long and now tw.
starting to say, um, you just debate
broed me when you lose a debate.
Really, is that really what we're doing
in big 25 going on 26 is crying about
the fact that someone asked you to
define terms?
You debate you debate broad me. That's
what that is. That's what that is.
It's not like a real point. He's just
exploring prop logic more. He doesn't
even exploring prop logic more. And that
that's why he stomped me on multiple
points in the conversation. Why became
an incoherent mess?
>> He I I think he gave a pretty reasonable
take the first time that it happened,
like the first time that the lawsuits
were announced. And he probably did just
get a little bit surprised by how much
opposition he got from [__] DG or
even people in here who are like the
[__] Ethan fans or whatever. And he
maybe thought like, well, that that like
level of blind loyalty is kind of
interesting to me. So I'm maybe and I'm
also going to like I'm getting a lot of
uh ascribed to my take. The f the first
time I saw Pisco required to this
first time I saw him react to this was
he was talking about how first of all
like he saw the the whatever statements
of intent. He was like God that's
[__] dumb. Like Jesus but then also
he was like he said he supported Ethan
protecting his copyright cuz he thought
that they all infringed.
>> He just didn't like the
>> He doesn't doesn't think he does anymore
though. Don't think he does anymore
though. He was saying the other night in
that um big Discord VC that all these
DJs kept trying to stream and um all
this [__]
you know, when he first looked at it, he
was like, "Okay, this is like delusional
and
Ethan's lying, [clears throat]
but broadly supportive." And because he
got push back, because the push back was
so insane, he started looking into it
more, really thinking about like why why
should you support a lawsuit? When
should you support a lawsuit? And has
changed his position. His position is
now firmer. His position is now this is
bad. It should not be happening as far
as I can tell. Yeah, exactly. He still
thinks they infringe. that his position
on the merits of the case hasn't changed
as far as I'm aware, but his position on
the the ethics of it I I believe have.
So, and there is no engagement with that
argument.
Not from Lonavox, that's for [__]
sure. Yeah, that debate the other day
was shameful, man. Totally shameful.
the fact that he was saying it had
something to do with like um
that it would have any effect on
precedent with regards to people like
Disney and [__] like that, which I think
is that's true. That's fair. And I think
because he said that, he probably got
into a lot um he probably got like a
much more disproportionate response than
he would have expected and then that's
probably just stuck with him a little
bit. It's like especially if you're like
fairly new to streaming and you're not
really used to the amount of like
disproportionate [__] behavior you
get for failing a loyalty test like
which is arguably what that was. I think
that's probably a better explanation for
him hinging on it than
whatever being bought and [__] paid
for by Dubbie or whatever. This doesn't
make sense. Doesn't make sense.
>> Yeah. Like listen to the world these
people live in where they're like
thinking about like they're failing
loyalty tests. They get disproportionate
hate for failing loyalty tests.
I cannot I I've actually never had a
moment where I'm like, "Oh, I just I
just failed a loyalty test. Oh, this is
a loyalty test." I mean, they I guess I
did fail a loyalty test with Dioro by
questioning this stuff.
But I don't think I got a
disproportionate
amount of hate for that. I was always
sort of antagonistic towards a lot of
Dior's audience. That that's just kind
of always been the the position I've
been in with bigger audiences. I've
always kind of like antagonistic to a
lot of them.
So I guess it's it is just only
something that you know
we've been on the plantation. You feel
it. I guess
>> why granted about was
>> and I should have thought about this at
the time. I think uh Mina mentioned it.
>> Yeah, we keep it chill. We keep it
leisurely. We we keep it leisurely.
Mina mentioned that
um
the whole thing about sincerity about
how sincere someone is when they're
doing the apology for a civil suit and I
was like
first of all I will completely double
triple quadruple down on the idea that
the whatever the heartfelt comment was
obviously tongue and cheek but the rest
of it um saying that you accept the
apology and whatever else and you're
happy to turn a leaf and move on I I
don't understand Like how
how would you settle a civil suit with
an apology and an acceptance and it not
feel unnatural?
I don't really unless unless like the
the actual act of a lawsuit really did
bring some kind of remorse and
reflection and the person who's uh
taking it is satisfied. I I would
imagine more often than not if you're
settling a civil lawsuit, it's probably
because both sides have agreed to
something that's preferable to going all
the way to a trial. And I think it'd be
very odd if Casey Tron did that apology
and then Ethan was like, "Yeah, well,
she's obviously speaking a lot of [__]
here, right? She's obviously talking
with a gun to her head like [__]
North Korea [__] ISIS video. We're
taking this all the way." So why did he
make her do the apology in the first
place? Dude,
>> all the way to the judge and the jury,
[__] Mad. No, I think in general
people are going
>> So there's like negative engagement from
this guy. It's so funny, man. I I love
the box. I love But
>> but these Ethan segments make me want to
bash my head against the [__] wall.
I'm sorry, but this guy sitting here
saying I'm I'm putting out a public
challenge at the box. This guy sitting
here saying I'm going to look into this
at some point. I'm going to look into
this at some point. Thank you for the
dono.
>> You may not know [music] it, but
Stardust is under the table right now,
and the grunts are a mix of trying to
make H3 fans feel at home while Misgust
going on.
>> That's disgusting. Thank you for the
333, but that's disgusting. Um, I I love
in the books, but these segments blow my
mind. And he needs to
like I think one day, here's what I
would love to see. Okay, this guy has
[__] all going on. This guy has [__] all
going on. I see his streams. Look at
this guy's stream. Look at this odd 11
hours he spends on stream. He watches
dog [__] Anything else? At first, he
watches the same Froggen [__] that
everyone else is watching for like
hours. He watches dog [__] Candace Owens
content, which just [__] blows.
And he spends like six hours playing
Hollow Night.
do one day, one day, one stream where
you actually try to go through all of
the content and justify the lawsuits,
okay? And point out the lies and and
actually say to your audience with their
lies. I want to be able to sit there and
watch and not have an episode, okay? And
not have a [__] episode watching it.
I would. It would be hilarious. Lonerox
would lose his like a third of his
audience in a day.
Not because it's boring content, but
because he would be forced to say things
that are unpleasant to that audience.
Because it is indefensible. It is
indefensible. And all of his segments on
this rely on him basically not knowing
what's going on or feigning ignorance. I
don't know which one it is. I'm assuming
it's not knowing what's going on. I have
quite a positive opinion of Lbox
generally.
I'm assuming he doesn't know what's
going on and he's just sort of like got
a little bit of motivated reasoning, but
it is like [__] absurd watching these
where it's just like he literally just
devolves into these incoherent
analogies.
It's just so [__] annoying. It's so
dumb, man.
>> Fairly
unnatural or fairly like
forced
softly forced in a civil lawsuit like
when they're giving a an apology and an
acceptance. But I don't think there's
anything wrong with that if the fact
that both of them want to move on and
settle is that's the sincere part,
right? Like, yeah, I don't know.
Whatever.
Whatever. Do you think Pisco might be
taking this position because Ethan
called him a fake lawyer? Um, no. I I
don't think the arguments that he's
making are like unbelievable. Like
that's the thing. Normally when people
normally when you want to say that
someone is acting for uh some kind of
like perverse motive or an an unnatural
motive then you have to first of all say
why their argument is so unbelievable
like why it's so bad but I just don't
think it is that crazy for him to
believe the things that he's saying. I
don't agree with all of it but
I don't know people I think people
should probably be a bit more people are
very quick to put people in boxes. Um,
and the only boxes in this house is me.
So, [clears throat] [__]
>> What do you mean what he's saying is
true? It's true in the most like
[__]
70 IQ
[__] first lawsuit you've ever
discussed way. Sure. If you're [__]
[__] what he's saying is true.
Yeah. Yes. Settlements are something
that is agreed upon by both parties.
You think Pisco is missing that? You
think Pisco doesn't understand that. Why
is Lonox even bringing this up? It's
like yet again saying you can sue anyone
you want. Everyone knows that, you
[__] idiot. Not relevant to any
argument being made. Did you know that
humans require oxygen? Did you know that
the sky is blue? Did you know? Like,
thanks, man. Seriously, great stuff,
bro. Really adding really adding to the
conversation. I'm glad we brought you
in. Yeah, I mean, most people are
[__] No, it's you being [__] if
you're sitting there saying that. Okay,
cuz Lavox understands that. Pisco
understands that and I understand that.
So, who the [__] is Lavox talking to?
Everyone understands this, right? It's
not relevant to any of the points being
made. It's like it's like literally like
we're talking about like,
you know,
we're we're like five steps down talking
about
the negative effects of smoking and then
you come in saying humans need oxygen.
It's like, yeah, no [__] Yes. It's like
prerequisite knowledge for even having
this conversation. Can you just like not
even bother saying that next time? Does
he cover any Ethan stuff today or do you
cover any more Ethan stuff in this
stream? I am interested Ethan coverage.
I am interested in watching this guy's
terrible Ethan coverage, man. I do enjoy
it. I do get a kick out of it.
>> [__]
We had we mental man like future.
>> Was it Oh, wait. I thought there was
Wasn't there some
>> The fact that he's going to all this
stuff though is like he's not naming
>> Oh yeah, apparently Hassan's threatening
to sue Lonox over copyright or
something. I know. I just saw his video
capitalist society. Like the fact is is
that Hassan just loves America. He loves
the American lifestyle. He loves the
American and he loves all the like
cringiest things about he loves all
>> all the opulence, all the [__]
consumerism,
the big [__] houses. He loves the the
big hot spot [__] coastal cities. He
just loves America. He's [laughter] like
a
He's an American poster boy.
All right.
I didn't even I forgot about this that
this that this lad was trying to stream
on Chinese Twitch.
>> I hate Tom Nichols. I hate Tom Nichols.
I hate Tom Nichols.
>> It's a Billy Billy.
>> I don't care about his ch stuff either.
Here we go.
Huge.
I could have just looked this up, but
>> dude, [laughter] I sued uh uh Boner Box.
>> Apparently, this is my mansion. Huge.
Huge.
I could have just looked this up. But
>> dude, [laughter] I sued uh uh Boner Box
openly in an effort to financially put
him underwater. And I basically found
like uh like a copyright reason to do
so, right? and I just [__] openly
sued him and I made him uh do an apology
in the process.
Do you think people would be talking
about how based it is? Do you think that
you know people would be
>> The difference is you [__]
hypocritical [__] is I first of all I
react pretty aggressively to everything
that you say like for
>> dude it's such cope man it's such cope.
No, you do not. You lying [__]
bastard. You have I have seen you play
WoW and watch your son. I have seen you
intermittently pause while doing other
stuff. Denims did a far more substantive
reaction to the content you than you did
to almost, you know, I I would say at
least 30% of the song content you
watched.
So, don't even [__] start that. I
hate this [__] high roading [__]
where he pretends his content is somehow
more transformative than others. There
is no material difference. There's no
distinction in the legal standards. It
is [__] absurd.
It is totally absurd.
>> For every [__] 5 seconds you talk,
I'll talk for like a minute about how
[__] stupid you are. And second of
all, uh I don't lie about you. I don't I
don't do like
>> What relevance does that have to
copyright? What relevance does that have
to copyright? Excuse me.
Also, I guarantee you may not have
deliberately lied. I would give a box
that guarantee I could find at least one
Dan Saltman lie that he has ran with
without fully checking. Guarantee. Would
put money on it.
>> Again, if I literally said, "Oh yeah,
let's just steal a bunch of Assan
content and do a shitty ass react." And
you sued me, then it's like, what what
grounds would I have to complain about
that? Like, I've clearly [__] around
in in the most obvious way, and if I
find out, well, [__] me. I guess that
would be that would be a real shame. But
what could I what could I say, you know,
like um
but as far as like any other underlying
pretext for you to have like a spiteful
or like a to have a vendetta against me,
dude, I don't lie about you. And I
literally have DMs I have DMs with the
son where he hasn't responded to this
last one, but I've literally said like,
"Yeah, if I ever say anything to you,"
because I I was correcting on something
he was saying about me a year ago. And I
said like, "Hey, if you ever see me
saying anything about you that you think
is out of context or unfair,
>> I'm going to be like Lab Box when Hassan
stops replying to my DMs, I'm I'm going
to become like Labox.
I'm going become like Labox.
That's going to be me soon when when the
son stops replying to me
>> or dishonest. Just tell me like I'll
correct it if you show me context or if
you say why I got something wrong. I'll
do that because I'm not you. I'm not
like you. We are different people. I'm
an honest person. You are a lying frat
[__] hyperconsumerist
desp
you know psychology came out there. I
fear
>> for it to simp for the [__] state of
China whilst enjoying all the benefits
of freedom living in the United States.
Laring [__] right? Is that is that
okay? Is that a big enough difference?
Also, you're a spoiled [__] And I'm
not. I'm a working-class hero. Okay.
Grew up in I grew up in hell.
>> I actually did. I came from a pretty
>> Scotland. Yeah, Scotland. Whatever. Yes,
all of Scotland.
>> Celebrating that [__] No, of course
not. They'd be calling it out because
that would be [__] ridiculous if I
did that.
Okay, [laughter]
>> I sued.
Whatever.
Go back to telling people how you uh at
least if at least if Assan ever did sue
me for copyright, I could probably like
fund raise to sue him for defamation for
the uh paid Israeli propaganda tour.
[laughter]
We can just do 50/50, you know, like
I'll just uh you get 10.
>> Wow. Terrible coverage as always. I've
got to say [__] terrible coverage.
Must be said that this coverage is
atrocious every time he does it.
Would love to see this fella, you know,
actually engage with the topic, engage
with the information
instead of just like blindly dick riding
doing this like, oh, I don't know
whenever it gets pressed.
That'd be cool.
Dude, oh my god, look at these
histrionic [__] women in my [__]
The memeification of Epstein has worked
to obscure the horror of his extensive
crimes. This man has raped and
trafficked children. He destroyed
countless lives, escaped account for
years due to his powerful network of
friends, associates, and
co-conspirators.
Bro, he he leisurely he chilling. He
leisurely he chilling. He's kind of
quirked up. He's kind of like, you know,
he's having a good time. Yeah. I'm just
trying to humanize him. Sorry. Yeah,
that was uh he's live today as well.
Let's let's finish off our loan box
coverage.
Let's finish off that checkups on on the
loan box Ethan Klein coverage.
>> Couple of bad fans are in those
communities.
>> He's still right now. Oh my god.
>> This looks like a
>> So he talks about denims. I guess
>> Donald Trump announced a new round of
global
>> taking bullets for Asmin Gold from
denims. But Asmin Gold, no. Get out of
the way. Asmin Gold, get down. tariffs,
raising rates on dozens of countries. At
the time of the announcement, the actual
tariff rate for China stood at 34%.
>> In response, the Chinese Communist Party
announced on April 4th that it would
impose a matching 34% tariff on all
goods imported from the US. Trump then
warned,
>> and you can see how this is
asymmetrical, right? Because like
obviously like we import way more than
they do from us.
>> That's not to do
>> China.
>> Puts the exact same tariff. This is
asymmetrical and unfair because we buy
more stuff that you guys make.
>> Straight denims. Do my job for me.
>> 50%. The CCP responded by saying it's
ready to fight to the end. While the
Chinese government is showing a tough
stance. Many businesses in China are
already feeling the pain.
>> See this is not like this is I think
where the problem is going to lie.
>> Where's the problem? is that like we all
watch that [__] from speed.
>> Like really, you can't look at Dude, he
doesn't care enough to look into any of
the lawsuits, but he just watches Denims
watch Asmin Gold for like extended
periods of time.
>> All right, man. Whatever, bro.
We can't possibly look into those
lawsuits that your big content creator
friend is uh doing. Could not ever
possibly do that.
What would the audience think? Oh, we
get some Hassan
to
>> the average American person, right?
Like, go get down. No, go, get down.
What about you? Why are you here,
>> dog? What about you?
>> Got him.
>> What the [__]
>> Absolutely [__] destroyed. I'm
>> You never mad cuz these are guys are
outside and that's the number one enemy
of Asmin go being outside.
>> Yeah. Looking at this happening on a
Saturday. Why are these guys not at
work? I don't know. That's a day people
work out, right? I think
>> I don't know. I don't go outside.
>> They have a fake job.
He called your chat the number one
anti-etic source in this platform
shooting our show chat [__] state and
again at the very least Asold is like
clever or he's clever he's just like the
thing with gold is that he just he's
going to win in the situation because as
gold actually uh says things that are
related to the average American person
right and not just this incredibly
[__] tight niche of hyper educate
like [__] college educated spoiled
rotten [__] middle class [__]
retards who have nothing to [__] show
for themselves they just have to pretend
that they're intellectuals because they
use some of the same [__] jargon that
was used by some philosopher in [__]
right
>> what is this other than seething about
the fact that the lefties
get upset with how you know like I don't
even want to say it man like yeah what
you mean by as gold says things that are
relatable to the average American is
that he is a careless leadrained
degenerate who worships death
and suffering and cruelty and believes
in causing maximum pain to other people
for no conceivable benefit to yourself
yes in that sense as gold as gold is
very relatable to the average American
Now, why is your coverage all about how
>> we still love Loner Box or is he going
in the grape cube?
>> Thank you for the £5. We love Lon Box.
Yeah. Um, thank Sorry, I thank you. Um,
what was I saying? [__] Where was I?
You interrupted me. Yeah. So, Asmin Gold
being like a total [__] you know,
psycho. Yes, that is relatable to
average. Why is your coverage of this
though just like, "Oh, yeah, Asd's going
to win. As God's awesome. As God's
awesome. As God's relatable." It
shouldn't be though. It shouldn't be.
Where's your positive liberal case here?
I understand you don't want to just
support Hassan, but where's your All
you're doing right now is saying, "Yeah,
Asen Gold's like chill. Where's your
positive liberal case here? Why do you
not make that?" Because that's that's
too middle class. And you know, you
couldn't possibly say it's bad to
massacre children. That sounds very
middle class and privileged. You know,
Asminag wouldn't say that. As God would
say, Asmin God would say, "If you've got
genocide baked into your culture, maybe
you deserve it." That's what Asagold
would say because he's relatable to the
average American. You know, that's what
it all feels like it comes back to, man.
But hey, let's let's see how it goes.
Let's see how it goes.
>> The difference is so [__] wide. You
got here speaking to a bridge between
the America first and the magards and
the [__] tariffs and the immigration
and the wall and all this [__] And you
got Mr. [__] [__] over here like
trying to explain to us the [__] like
the [__] nuances or the the moral
necessity of kidnapping [__]
civilians in the Red Sea to stop the
active ongoing genocide in [__] Gaza.
Somehow those two are connected. [__]
sipping for the CCP and talking about
how great they are with uh balancing
rural and urban development. Talking
about how the [__] Middle Eastern
countries like the conservative Muslim
nations would be uh they'd be hammering
on the doors of gay rights just as long
as American bombs stop dropping on them.
You know, all Saudi Arabia needs is to
stop getting bombed by the United States
and then they'll become pro like who's
going to win this [__] ideal goal.
Who's going to more effectively capture
the minds of the average American lost
and confused young male [__] on the
It's [__] This is the push back we
have on Twitch to [__] American. I'd
be [__] breaking it. Clip. No. No.
This is a man who is consistent. There's
no way. So in the same in the same week
where he was uh salivating at the
prospect of
>> Yeah. The push back certainly coming
from you is it l
>> a collaborative stream with Nick Fendes
as his shadow was spamming base when
Nick was like Adolf Hitler was awesome.
He turned around and said I was the
number one source. My community was the
number one source of anti-semitism on
the platform. No.
No. That seems so farfetched cuz really
you make a micro when you cry for a
joke. You want free speech. This is a
very specific thing and this is how many
[__] videos does cocker make about me
getting potentially or getting arrested
because I'm the number one anti? How
many videos do you make about Muhamm and
how it's totally justifiable to [__]
deport him? The [__] is this? Wow. Wow.
Going from going from [__] Mama Khil.
Absolutely. Yeah. Has to be decision if
these guys not have a conversation. I
feel like Assan would probably wipe the
floor with gold.
>> He has multiple times
>> cuz MAGA is just there that indeible.
Does he know? I'm guessing maybe does
he? They spoke before. Yeah. Based
you know the number one cause of
anti-semitism is Israel. Why is nobody
tackling Israel? H the rats are jumping
ship. It seems he's getting caught on my
time so much lately for being a [__]
hypocrite. Yeah. No, for sure. For sure.
Yeah. How many videos did he do on his
anti-semitic? Now he's over here talking
about how uh Puka doing the u puka doing
the the anti-semitic gent memes is
actually
>> debated about all his protest in 2023. I
thought it was more recent than that. I
thought they debated about Israel and
stuff that more recently was where the
[__] wasn't when said that thing
about how the Palestinians have baked
into their minds and [__] Um their
Islamic ideology and that was the debate
wasn't when was preaching to and
response was to tell all about how
actually all of these conservative
Muslim nations and societies would would
uh would be [__] would be opening up
to the gay rights just as soon as the
Americans start dropping bombs on them.
It's literally the only thing standing
between the Muslim Arab world and gay
rights is [__] America. Jesus.
>> Just like silliness. If he starts the
word terrorist, half of
>> that where the Houthan and Franklin came
from. God, he's so lucky that hasn't
gold is too [__] to He's so lucky
that has gold too hard to know is see
through the amount of [__] [__] that
comes out of his guy's face. I think the
reason so much. Um it's not just because
it's just like it just covers like it's
just one of those places where left
wingers can still actually appeal to
liberals.
>> Well, this is a very strong positive
liberal case being made here. I can see
why I I just it's a mystery why
Kami Hassan is so popular and liberal
owner box is still still you know same
viewership. It's like
it just blows my mind that you can
really sit here
and do this every day where you just
like you just piss and [__] about Hassan
and like even when you're looking at
Asmin Gold it's still about Hassan. It's
so crazy. Like you've got you've got
Hassan and Asminold there. I understand
you might hate both of them equally if
you're like a moderate lib. That that
might be reasonable. Fair enough.
Well, then great opportunity for you to
voice that
for you to be making some kind of
positive case. Where is it? Where is it?
Or do you just cry about the fact that
other people have terrible push back?
just cry about the fact that Hassan says
that
causing countries to become more
impoverished and more unstable generally
does not lead to positive social
outcomes. You just get cry about him
saying that would not come up with your
own formulation, your own vision.
Like it's just like worthless, bro. I
would probably like obviously if Hassan
actually said and I don't think he did.
I think this is a [__]
interpretation, deliberately [__]
interpretation from Lonabox here,
frankly,
where Hassan is probably saying
something to the effect of yes, unstable
countries with issues with the the basic
necessities, you know, the basic parts
of the hierarchy of needs aren't met,
struggle to get to the later parts as as
you can probably imagine because you
need to kind of have a good baseline,
start thinking about stuff like rights
and you know, for much of human history,
western countries didn't even have all
this stuff cuz it was like, you know,
we're like [__]
surfs out working the fields and
everyone's dying of like easily
preventable diseases and all this [__]
So, at a certain point once you've got
some needs met and people have time to
[__] think about this and space to
breathe, yeah, you do start solving
those issues more. Now, is that to say
that there's no effect of culture and
religion and all this stuff on the
ability for a country to do that and
that change have to be made there?
Obviously, no. Obviously, he's not
saying any of that. She's not saying any
of that. I'm not saying there's no, you
know, attitude or culture there that's
independent of of um any poverty or or
suffering they're they're experiencing.
But this stuff does have an interplay.
So, Loner Box,
Hassan's presented his idea. As
presented his idea, I've now presented,
you know, my idea. Are we going to get
Loner Box's ideas at any point in this
clip or is it just going to be another
excuse to sit there and cry about her
song the entire time?
>> Like quite horrible. But it's also
because they can uh ride on the fact
that people just don't know enough about
it. People don't care enough about it.
They don't care enough to know. And then
even it's very easy for someone who's
just basically been [__] doped to the
gills on propaganda pamphlets and go
there and act like a [__] scholar and
they don't know what to say in response.
But
>> is your face as the thumbnails?
>> Okay. I thought you were exaggerating.
It's not an exaggeration.
I'm risking another ban. What is this
content new [__] He can't stop talking
about me.
>> Wait, Hassan uses Filmore.
>> I searched the term terrorist on as gold
TV channel and it's mostly just videos
about me. That's crazy. Hassan got
banned.
>> Don't support terrorist then [__] You
support terrorists. Yeah, of course.
It's one of the digger about you is that
you're a [__] [clears throat]
American ass like hyperconumer opulent
fra spoiled [__] who for some reason
needs to support terrorists. That's
that's really it's fascinating.
[clears throat]
>> I warned you. openly promoting terrorist
propaganda. If you disagree with them,
go to China and protest them. I'll wait.
What? Go to China. I live in America,
you [__] idiot. And he unironically
wants to turn America into what you
think China is.
If you disagree with them, go to China
and protest them. I'll wait. [laughter]
Wait. Wait. What you think? What do you
think China has free speeches on? What
do you mean? We have to go to America
and do what you think China is. Okay,
that's the argument here. Okay. The
argument that I'm presenting is that you
should be able to protest. Also, I did
go to China. It was a [laughter]
He's so [__] thick, man. He's
actually like
He's actually so dense. What the [__]
What was that sentence? Go to China and
protest them. Protest them. Protest.
Protest the thing you can't do in China.
Protest the regime. You cannot do that
in China. Why don't you go to China and
start asking [__] about the regime? Lead
a protest. [clears throat] I did
actually go to China. Dude, you're such
a [__] You're such a bad manipulator.
It's so [__] stupid. What the [__]
>> Is manipulator like, dude, why does all
this like um Bro, it's always like it's
like the frat thing manipulator. It's
like
>> I don't even want to say it, man.
>> Did go to what? [__] me, man. The next
time someone tell me to go to Israel and
fight with the IDF, bro. I did. I went
to Israel. Excuse me. What? You there
pictures camel.
>> China is that's the argument here.
>> How is he doing that?
>> The argument that I'm presenting is that
you should be able to protest. Also, I
did go to China. It was awesome. He's
talking about nitizen protesting in the
US. Yeah, except unlike China,
non-citizens
on US soil, you [__] [__] I think
pride of me from the entrenched among
army fan is just that because they don't
have leader house or what is that? Um I
think I know it there. Okay.
>> They probably would why throw that. Oh,
I did go to China. Okay.
>> And you were right about
>> Yeah, that's more it that's more it.
Stacy always goes for the communists.
That that's that's more along the lines
of where my head's at.
>> Legal assessment was correct. His
wasn't. I remember because he had a Wily
who was right attitude. Yeah. Did they
ever actually do a follow-up to say
Hassan was right? I was wrong. I was a
dumb [__] who doesn't know anything.
who was just simply chirping into the
[__] wind because
>> it just all seems it just again whenever
I watch the content like it is all just
like so wrapped up in some [__]
bizarre, you know, I I don't even know
what to call it. Like I don't want to
overuse psychosexual like Freudian. I
don't even know what you'd call it, man.
It's just all there's just always this
weird high school sexual element to it.
It's just bizarre.
>> Explain what grip is. It's easy to tell
someone how they go against their own
side. If they never go against their own
side, they're grifting. Wait, what is
these? What the [__]
>> This is a proper little [__] pack
going on.
>> They never go against their own side.
How many match up though? It's cute.
>> As gold crafted around me yelling at my
chat.
I never go against my own side. I think
that's a very stupid metric for whether
someone has a grifter or not. But even
by that own silly ass metric that he
[__] presents.
I [__] on leftist principles and the way
that leftists operate the way that the
leftist present themselves themselves on
the internet and all around with regular
frequency.
>> He shits on leftists who [__] on him to
be fair. He shits on like he'll shab
after [__] on him for what? Okay. a lot
more than As Gold shits on Donald Trump,
for example.
What a [__] statement. To be clear,
like I don't I need to [__] prove it
to people like I [__] gold.
[laughter] The way that the [__] that he
supported the last year like with
regards to Khalil or with Garcia with
all the deportations and the [__]
economic like the fact that he just kind
of swoops in and just watches all this
like random propaganda [__]
>> As go bad at the end, guys. As I know I
spent the whole time crashing out of
crashing out of Stacy always goes for
the commies.
As go bad at the end. Good job.
I just wish there was like any I don't
know, man.
Does he think about his content past
just being like a
reactive drone? Like just being like,
"Oh, his song clip. I [__] hate this
guy." Like, does he think about it past
that? Does he think about like, "Oh,
what am I saying on my streams?" Cuz I
feel like this would be like a great
time to just lay out like if you're in
between these two positions, great time
to lay out your middle position. Great
time to make that positive case, but
it's just not there. It's not there.
It's just more bitching about Hassan.
It's just like watching more Pegasus.
It's like watching Pegasus content or
Nick Dioro content except Lone the Box
is like 30 IQ points higher and way
above doing this [__]
where you just like sit there and go,
"Oh, this guy's a [__] comedy and he
he b he buys cars. He buys expensive
cars."
Just shut up, man. Just shut up.
>> [__] left wingers are more violent
than right wingers for terrorism in the
United States. Like
it's just it's so [__] that like the
push back to it is is this on Twitch.
God has been while hygiene as bigger
fish to fry his personal hygiene.
Cringe. What a state. Oh, just so you
guys know, both are grifters. They're
not grifters. You think that's even why
they're doing his gripping if you
griffing is those two both are very
authentic in their opinions
unfortunately. In the descript
box, brother.
>> Yep. I love it. Speaking of I guess
other new goal, I know just a short one.
Oh yeah, this was from the Epstein thing
as well. This is hard to point talking
about it. Um, this is the opening uh
sentence from Lolita written on
someone's foot and a [__] copy of the
book. This is from
>> She was low, plain low in the morning
standing 4 foot 10 in one sock. Dude,
[__] mental.
It's only the first half. Yeah, I think
this ep guy might be a pervert. What's
the next half? It's not the exact
opening line. It's part of the opening.
It's this. Lolita li of my life fire my
loins my sin my soul low lip pa the tip
of the tongue taking a trip of three
steps down pallet to top I had three on
the teeth
>> you really reading this she was low four
feet and one sock she was in slack she
was doll at school she was on the dotted
line but in my arms she was always a
leader Jesus [__] you can't feel that
a foot though contra point I'm sorry
what's he saying the first half is
dogarded what
>> I don't know whatever Jesus
they're saying that he only read the
first he's like read the first half a
whole bunch and hasn't really read the
second half so much
I'm guessing my understanding is based
on My understanding of the book of Lisa,
having not read it, is that I imagine
the first half is more about the
relationship he's building with this
child and the latter half is more about
him suffering for for the consequences
of that decision.
I would imagine based on my knowledge of
the book.
Wait, what's he saying? The first half
is bgeeared. What? I don't know.
Whatever. Jesus. Are we not allowed to
appreciate classical? Oh, he's talking.
Oh, he's not a [__] book. I'm a
readard. Jesus. Okay. Yeah, this this he
only read the first Oh, no. What a
[__] psycho. Okay, got it. I'm so
sorry. Okay, there we go. He got it.
He got it.
He's watching like Dude, please don't
tell me. No,
>> no, he's really watching these awful
>> Nick Doro orbit videos.
>> Bro, you you literally you're spending
your time watching this and you can't
look into your [__] the [__]
lawsuit at all. You can't do anything to
look into the lawsuit. You're watching
the [__] Princess Mantis channel. The
[__] absolutely mentally disabled
Nick Dioro orbit who uses AI for all
these dog [__] edits.
>> Dude, it's like beyond [__] parody,
bro.
>> Um,
>> it's so cringe, man. It's so cringe. I
can't take it. I have to just stop
>> with people on the extremes.
>> Oh, he watches some of this dispell
[__]
>> We're snarking loss.
I think you're perfectly capable and
very cogent to be able to dive into the
nuance of that is demanded of these
issues who are familiar with the topic.
But what I'm saying is it's not you
that's [__] It's not me that's
[__] who's trying to do this binary
when you're propagandizing spreading
politics across the internet. People are
[__] They're going to fall into one
of two camps. It was society of the
capitalists which
>> okay I don't care about this and I guess
I guess he has people on. Do they talk
about the Ethan stuff?
>> Go on. Hang on.
Yeah, I can have more African African
roots.
>> Yo, I'm so glad I finally realized that
Spider's Hispanic. I'm so glad I finally
placed the voice.
>> It makes so much sense with the
>> It's not really It's not really bible
stuff though. It's like it's just it's
just the kind of discourse I just I'm
not really interested in. Like I don't
want to It's just like not fun for me.
>> So yeah, people are breaking rules or
anything. It's just that like I'm not
going to ask them to make their
moderating decisions different or
whatever else. But like I don't know why
I'd be in like [__] queen stream and
people are in the chat saying that I
support cyber steer like that's I don't
know why that should be a thing. Um
>> do you think maybe it's because you
can't you constantly get really annoyed
by it? He said he he's complaining. I
we've just gone to a random point. He's
got he's just complaining. The people in
this chat say he supports Sabra and
Shhat or that his his dad was involved
in it or whatever as a joke obviously
because it [__] with him because it
annoys him and they don't like him.
I I look if you don't like, you know,
like [__] posting and people [__]
around and trolling,
then yeah, you're you're probably not
going to you might not, you know, drive.
But acting like this is some serious
thing or that you're being sing you're
like, you know, unique is pretty cringe,
bro. Okay, let's let's listen. Let's
hear what he's saying, man.
Yeah, remember when he crashed out over
the question marks, dude. I love Lo I do
love Labox. So listen, he is very
sensitive like he's very sensitive
>> man like that everything like he wants
to bait
>> should be
>> I think he talked about like um how you
were at McDonald's and then the Roman
asked you like hey yo bro drop the full
lore about and way too [__] lore.
Yeah that was a [__] I dropped all
the lore I just can't do it. Yeah I got
a little map out and we just yapped.
Yeah. Um well, did he cuz the I think
under relevant cliff which I run. Um I
think he debated Jtock Gman and Shre
about the whole Ethan Klein [__] 31
>> or basically a 2v one 3v1 basically. So
>> to be fair I don't really like
>> I mean I' I've actually even said this
to them like I I just don't like
interacting with that community because
I feel like
>> something something happens there's two
things that happens when I interact with
that community. one is just slightly
annoying, but is like is that um people
will try to just look for like a
10second clip of me saying something
that they can conrue as some like mad
[__] Zionist position or like like I
think the last thing was like asking me
about um would it be anti-semitic to say
that you want one state solution right
like I want right now would that be
anti-semitic and I said like kind of in
the sense that it would probably yield
anti-semitic outcomes like not
understanding the like
>> that's not what you said
where's the clip H. Oh, thank you,
Kathy.
>> So,
>> well, yeah, I said that.
I Okay, so you wait. So, okay. So, you
think it's anti-Semitic to believe one
person, one vote now?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Okay. So, you think that is an
anti-Semitic belief? Not Not just
anti-semitic in practice, but anti-mitic
in motivation?
>> I don't think it has to be in
motivation. Mostly people have no
[__] idea. But you think, but you
think because that would lead to the
death of Jews in Israel that
>> that's anti-semitic.
>> Uh yeah.
>> Um
so that's the that's the clip he's mad
about. So let's hear how he phrased it
just then cuz he makes it sound like he
was like, "Oh, you know, maybe in like
the way that it I'm okay. Let's just
hear what he says. Let's hear what he
says.
>> Happens. There's two things that happens
when I interrupt that community. is just
slightly annoying, but it's like it's
that um people will try to just look for
like a 10-second clip of me saying
something that they can conrue as some
like mad [__] Zionist position or
like like I think the last thing was
like asking me about um would it be
anti-semitic to say that you want one
state solution right like I want right
now would that be anti-mitic and I said
like kind of in the sense that it would
probably yield anti
>> kind of no you did you did not say kind
of you did not let's run that back
>> okay so you wait so okay so you is
anti-semitic to believe one person, one
vote now.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Okay. So, this is what I mean, man. This
is where I get pissed off with people
like Lona Mox and Hutch so bad.
>> You wanted to be in this debate. You
wanted to go hard. You wanted to stand
on it. You wanted to say, "Oh, yeah. Oh,
yeah."
Then when people take an implication
from your such firm stance there.
It's Oh, I didn't even say that. I
didn't even say that. I said kind of.
No, you didn't. You wanted to be firm on
this question. You wanted to make a firm
point. The lefties didn't like it. It
got you some, you know, I don't know. I
guess I think this was a BE. He's
probably upset cuz this was in a BE
video. I'm I'm guessing that's the case
because I believe it was I believe it
was in a BE video. I'm guessing that's
that's the part that's annoyed him.
[clears throat]
Maybe just don't answer like this in the
first place cuz it's going to be
clipped. It's a live stream. We all have
to deal with that. We all have to deal
with that. So, if there's a if there's a
question that might cause you backlash,
you know, you can decide how to answer
that. You do not have to go, "Oh, yeah.
You don't have to do that."
Just like Hutch does not have to go,
guys. It's not a war crime to bomb
hospitals.
You know, you don't have to do that. You
don't have to say it like that. And you
can't, you know, cry foul when people
take it the way you said it
>> right now. Would that be anti-mitic? And
I said like kind of in the sense that it
would probably yield anti-semitic
outcomes like not understanding the like
need for a Jewish majority like in
Israel is it is like would kind of have
that outcome. It's not inherently
anti-semitic to like you know democracy
but but people took that clip and
basically just said like oh Lord thinks
like opposing apartheid is anti-semitic.
I'm like well no. Yeah. So like that
kind of stuff happens quite a bit when I
interact with those groups like the
[__] that crowd like the band of
whatever.
>> Yeah, that's obviously like that's
obviously a [__] conclusion to take.
It's obviously a [__] conclusion.
Obviously the the the scope of the
question is about like break ending it
right now with no like process or
whatever. Like obviously yes that's
totally there's arguments you can make
around that. No one's [__] saying
otherwise. No one reasonable saying
otherwise.
But you have to deal with the fact you
will be clipped. You cannot just cry
foul about the clips.
And this is just the endless problem
with these people.
Hassan does it too, don't get me wrong,
but they cry about it when Hassan does
it. When Hassan's like, "That's a bad
faith clips out of context." Like, oh,
how would you possibly say that?
Everyone has to do a clipping
clips up because they somehow get from
there to those guys. Um, and there's
people clipping looking for that kind of
stuff. And the other personal attacks
and [__] DMs and [__] like that come
up as well. So, I just like I feel like
I just don't need either of those things
in my life. And like I don't think it's
like a moderation problem necessarily.
It's just Yeah. I don't know. Just weird
[__] goes on there.
>> Dude, what?
>> [__] DMs and [__] like that come up
as well. So I just like I feel like I
just don't need either of those things
in my life. And it's like I don't think
it's like a moderation problem.
>> Is he mad cuz I said I I cuz I said I
DM'd him that I was angry about that
video cuz I did cuz I messaged him being
like this is a terrible video.
He's mad about that dude. It's like so
crazy. He just wants to sit there. It
feels like he just wants to sit there,
do like three hours of watching the rest
of politics in near silence, which don't
get me wrong, I love doing that every
once in a while. Three hours of watching
the rest of politics and CNN in near
silence. 3 hours of holiday night in 3
hours of crying about Assan and and
never never engage anyone, never have an
argument, and never be forced into a
position where he might have to
reconsider an opinion. It's so
frustrating watching this guy, man. He
seems like such a just s comes off so
sensitive and closed off, you know. Get
get some constitution. Figure it out.
Engage with the topics. Engage with the
interesting topics. Like it just feels
like he just spends his time getting
into fights with lefties
so that he can cry about how they're
treating treating him and and never
engage with anything remotely
interesting.
>> Sarly. It's just Yeah, I don't know.
Just weird [__] goes on there.
[__] Have they DM'd you? Like any other
like like have any other fans like DM
you or
>> um It's
[snorts]
>> It sounds like it's like a crazy
harassment. Maybe it might not be.
>> It's not really like it's not really
like bannable stuff though. It's like
it's just it's just the kind of
discourse that I just don't I'm not
really interested in. Like I don't want
to it's just like not fun for me. Like
so
>> yeah. It's not like people are
>> bring nothing is no discourse is fun for
you. Let's be [__] serious. Unless
you are sitting in a in a university
classroom
where you can just sit there and, you
know, present present your little papers
and read them out to each other, you're
never going to be having fun. And that
ain't streaming.
Like I'm like, I'm not going to ask them
to make their moderating decisions
different or whatever else. Like, but
like I don't know why I'd be in like
[__] Queen and stream and people are
in the chat saying that I support Cyber
Satilla, right? Like that's I don't
>> I don't know why that should be a thing.
Um, but it is. So,
>> oh yeah,
>> not [__] with that. No fun.
>> I mean, I feel like it's shittier that
he doesn't like say anything about to
those people or like, you know, that's
not true or what.
>> Guys, that's not true, guys. I'm going
to make it totally totally clear to you
guys right now. Lonabox does not support
the Sabbranch TM mask.
>> There's no reason Lon Box would support
the Sarbranch TM massacre. It doesn't
line up with any of his other stated
beliefs and he simply would not support
that. So, guys, I'm sure that's going to
stop you now, isn't it? Wow.
>> I mean, I think he probably he probably
does. Like, I I don't know. I don't
>> Yeah. No [__] Yeah. No [__] Actually
believe it. You don't actually believe
it. They're [__] with you.
>> He says I've watched him talk about me a
couple of times. Like, um,
but it's only in like small bits.
>> Do Do you think that he has good faith
towards you?
>> No. Like, what the [__] One time he was
watching um
>> I I was actually going to react to it on
stream, but then I just realized it
wasn't worth it. There was one um there
was one thing where he was like talking
about the Israel Palestine stuff
covering me talking about I think it was
Qatar or something but I think he he
summarized my approach to Israel
Palestine discourse is just me spuring
out and saying that people are too
[__] to know how sniping jobs work
and I'm like really that's your summary
of how I approach Israel Palestine like
the
>> that that is yes yes yes
I'm talking about your rhetoric there
I'm talking about your attitude on
stream yes we understand loner box
you've spent many many hours reading
boring text documents.
No one watches you read boring text
documents. Whenever you're in a position
where you are going to give an argument
that is going to be seen by people, you
resort to being condescending towards
people for having justified horror at
videos they're seeing of people dying.
That is essential. That is basically in
summary how your rhetoric works. It's
like, I can't believe you'd be upset
about these videos of these kids dying
to the point where you're calling it a
war crime. You're such an idiot for
saying that. That's how your rhetoric on
this goes and has gone for like the last
year as far as I can tell. Yes. Yes.
That's appeal to emotion. Nice one.
It's just like it blows my mind. And
look, I'm not going to say that I I'll
even show this is my show of good faith.
I understand immediately. I can
immediately understand why Loner Box
would hear me say something like that,
not be able to perceive the point prop
that I'm trying to make
and shut off a little bit. Much like a
lefty would hearing someone say it's not
hospital, it's not a war bomb hospitals
or you don't know how sniping jobs work.
Much like a lefty would shut off in
those situations. I understand how you
have shut off hearing me say that in a
mean way, but I think loan box, if you
seriously do some time and take some
time to introspect, you'll understand
the point I'm making. It's
absurd
to constantly spend your time on stream
crying how you're the [__] victim of
all these lefties when you make
absolutely no effort
to alter how you're perceived. Because
it's not just a couple lefties that
think it. It's getting picked up that
way by huge amounts of the audience. The
>> amount of [__] like ungodly hours I
spent reading more about this conflict
than like immediately. Yes. What did I
say? We know you've done a lot of
reading, Loner Box. No one's discounting
your reading. Every time I talk about
it, guys, how many times have I said
Loner Box is incredibly intelligent and
very well read on the Israel Palestine
stuff? Lab Box is far more well read
than I could ever be on the Israel
Palestine stuff. How many times? How
many times have we said this?
Many every every time I've discussed
Lone Works talking about this, I would
say I have said that I have made that
exceedingly clear
>> combined doing most of it on stream. Um
>> yeah, literally too many to the point
where people get annoyed with it.
>> So [__] careful to try and like um
with every kind of like wild claim that
comes my way to verify things are true
or not. And then like summarizing that
is what my position is when it's a clip
that wasn't even from a [__]
>> Dude, I didn't summarize it. It's just
your position, you [__] idiot.
>> Segment that I uploaded is just like
like that. That's that's you just
talking like a bad
>> I said every every clip I probably I
think if I'm remembering back I believe
the thing I said was something
effective.
Every clip I see is similar to that
sniping jobs clip.
He's spoking out on being condescending
at people who have probably reasonable
feelings of horror. I don't know if it
was those words. That was the point I
was making. I'm positive of it.
>> I'd have a fan. Like there's no
difference. Or a son van. And I'm just
like that. No, that's not good faith.
No, cuz he knows better.
>> Is Guys, he knows that because he's
watched so much of the content from the
30 seconds he could stand to watch
before he punched his monitor after
someone put a question mark in the chat.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean,
>> I've never acknowledged his his
knowledge level is Palestine more allied
with his community or didn't you used to
like raid him or that kind of stuff, you
know?
>> Yeah, but again, like if he's got if he
changes opinions on me, that's fine.
Like he's allowed to.
>> Um,
but I just I'm just saying why I don't
bother like going interacting directly
with those spaces anymore.
>> I I understand. Um, it does seem like
there's a lot of toxicity over there
anyway. Um, like among that whole
sphere. So, um I don't know how much
overlap like yeah I don't I don't even
necessarily know entirely like where all
those people if they're all just like
bada people or if they're like anti-Asan
people or um or if it's or sorry anti-
Ethan people or if it's both and you
know how much like
>> if somehow okay if there's like some
like evidence that like those can be
like probab then like what the [__] No,
they're not like they're they're Yeah,
I'm pretty sure they
>> Dude, like spider is so disabled, bro.
>> Get this guy in a home. This guy needs
someone wiping his ass. It's [__]
insane,
watching his content. So, um, but
yeah, I'm not saying they're the same.
I' I know I've definitely seen like a
couple of Banana fans are in those
communities. Um, but met that [__]
amilaration station guy. He's he's
there.
>> Oh, that guy. Remember that guy?
>> Whose name is that? Who's Who is that?
>> I don't know.
>> Do we think that's the same guy who
constantly makes an alt and then comes
into chat and says some insane [__]
>> No, I have no idea who that is. Whoever
that person is, I [clears throat] think
that person is History Speaks
>> because he always uses that same talking
point. So, it's either that or he's the
one dedicated History Speaks fan. Like,
it's it's one of those.
>> Neither was Give me cafe
mate,
>> bro. People on LSF think I'm like Laur
account. It's kind of
>> Wait, what?
>> People think on LSF like when they see
like a L box post, they think they be
thinking like, "Yo, is this a L box?"
Uh, what the [__]
>> Well, yeah. That's because you call
yourself my [__] name, but then you
also do streams with the
>> Hell yeah. Hell yeah. You know what I
do? Okay. I am.
>> Maybe you should uh Yeah, maybe you
should get your own brand, dit.
Okay. I'm like I'm a true I'm a true
>> dude. This guy's a parasite.
>> That's true. That's true. Capitalistic
socialist. Okay. Is very true. Okay.
Sharing. Sharing is caring. Okay. Look
at [laughter]
Okay. Has a billion billion channels.
Okay. A billion. Okay. Dead ass. Like
I'm like the only [__] nor channel.
Okay. [__] sadly.
>> So Eclipse industrial complex.
>> Okay. Let's let's see if there's any
more here.
>> Views. What the [__]
>> Destiny unprompted.
Unrelated. Wait, what?
>> Discord.
>> I don't know. Wait, did I lose all my my
rosaries again? Oh, no.
>> Everybody in chat thinks it's box.
Relax. Okay. Oh, my [__] broccoli.
>> Check up click.
>> Is it all the way over there?
>> I am that
>> is my
>> most of it.
>> Have to just have like 20 that this
person knows nothing that they shouldn't
they should not have an opinion on this
conflict like online. Like it's it's 20%
of their population living there sort of
thing. But if you have someone who's
literally like [__] you say that you
mention uh why would you call Israel an
ethnic state? Because ethnic states
don't usually have like 20% of their
population living there uh with equal
rights and not in camps. And then their
response is to go well they are in
camps. Look at the West Bank. It's like
I mean you need to make it very clear
that this person knows nothing that they
shouldn't they should not have an
opinion on this conflict like online.
Like it's it's like socially and morally
irresponsible for them to have an
opinion if that's their response to you
saying that right. Like if you're
talking about 20% of the population like
Israel proper and talking about um them
having equal rights and not living in
camps and their response is to say the
West Bank and also they do live in camp.
I I guess it's a stupid response, but I
don't think that's a very good argument
for why Israel is not an ethnost state.
But sure,
>> whatever.
>> Destiny's with the sons. But um yeah, I
don't know. [__] He's just got he's on
his journey.
>> I I can't humor this [__] position of
like
why is this
>> the first comments are usually like
anti-Lord fans or like pro Hassan like
the heat of that sometimes like n they
actually like remove the [__] But when
I post like irrelevant for some reason
they don't they don't remove the post
usually cuz like maybe because he's
black and they don't want like the heat
of that probably don't want the heat of
like being anti-black. So that's my
theory.
>> [__]
>> That's my theory. Oh too post like
Lornbox [__] Usually the first comments
are usually like anti Lornbox fans who
like all the all the anti-Hassan heads
enter inside the comment and like upload
to the post.
>> Well that's basically because Hassan
originally Jesus Christ that's action if
they were against him but now obviously
because Asmin Gold is the more powerful
>> pro Hassan usually right. He used to
brigade the threads and get lost control
of the platform and on the gold reacts
to Lordan.
>> What the [__] is this [__]
>> Like really is half the stream is about
>> so cool.
>> Did I ask didn't I ask you on on [__]
stream like a 20 page uh question? So
what the [__] And you know what? Guess
what [__] I interviewed Dyl
Burns. Okay, [__] You have it.
I did [__] I did. I can live
that down history. I interviewed someone
who was actually cringe who was actually
there. I go to this I can't remember the
[__] I don't like again he has an
unhealthy obsession with my unhealthy
assign obsession it's done that for
months you were just at the bridge
>> the queen being an insane anti-an
reacting to learn was a surprise for me
no he's done that for months I don't
like again he has an unhealthy obsession
with my unhealthy assan obsession it's
>> I don't care to I I don't get it like
gun to gun to his head his politics
obviously align more with mine than his
his politics probably align more with
>> I I say dude like it's like insane
I can say a thousand times times over
what my politics are. I can make
positive cases for exactly what I think
almost all of these segments. I can I
can fight with like [__] lefties in
my chat and retired righties in my chat
and still they sit there like as if it's
like some [__] mystery like as if I'm
sat here like there's a question about
whether I I actually wow I actually
really agree with the song and like
everything
[laughter]
and then I'll post on my second channel
I'll post about Zach Palansky and how
much he's a [__] and everyone's like
oh wow so you just want all immigrants
gone and you reform
>> [laughter]
>> Kill me, dude. Kill me.
>> Destiny isn't with the sons, but um
yeah, I don't know. [__] He's just got
he's on his journey.
>> I I can't humor this [__] position of
like
center left and like liberal or social
democrat type people being stuck with
these two extremes of [__] MAGA
fascism reform and then the other side
like the tanky [__] brain rot like
free Palestine brackets. We love Hamas.
Uh and the Houthies type [__] And then
but people coming to people coming to
people like me who apparently have like
similar politics to me and just going
like and just like [__] concern
trolling about the
>> cuz you're excusing a bunch of
disgusting [__] and you know better.
Okay. I do it to all of you. I do it to
Hutch. I do it to Nicholas Dioro. I do
it to Lonabox because you're excusing a
bunch of disgusting [__] You're
literally like excusing someone making
everything [__] worse for all of us.
you're totally failing on your your
obligations as a content creator,
failing on your own principles if you
actually bothered to look into any of
the details or into your own into your
own heart. And so, you deserve it.
So, you deserve it. You need to be told.
It's just that simple. Especially Loner
Box. Literally, especially Loner Box
because he really could be better and
should be better. He really could and
should be better. So, especially Loner
Box. Nicholas Dioro
is an actual low life. No one ever
really questioned that. It wasn't like
some big like, "Oh, no, Nick's actually
a really great guy." So, he's fine. He's
a content creator. It's fine. Nicholas
Dioro is a [__] low life, a fat idiot
who has fat person mindset. I truly
don't believe he's capable of making
himself better in any way.
That's how people like that tend to
work.
Hutch is mentally disabled.
And I mean that I think something has
happened wrong to his brain. I think he
is either, you know, some some abuse or
whatever that he's put that he's done to
it. Not abuses in he abuse he's done to
his brain uh has has caused some kind of
damage,
some kind of trauma. I think he is too
stupid to engage with a lot of this and
does just run an impulse.
None of that's true about Lonabox.
Lonabox can read. Lonabox can write.
Lonabox can think through an issue. I've
seen it happen many times. I see it
happen with Israel Palestine when he's
not just like I say sping out and being
condescending
as I've said many times.
Thank me Q. Thank you.
So yeah, especially so yes, I do have an
unhealthy obsession with your unhealthy
Hassan obsession.
But I'm right.
But I'm right
and you earned it. So
way that I respond to extreme
communities. Like it's just I have no
time for that. It's just like it's a
dead weight. It does nothing for me.
>> Like
I mean like for I mean I think some
[__]
>> So it just comes through, doesn't it? He
just doesn't care to look into the Ethan
lawsuit stuff because it's this is how I
deal with those communities. I just um
yeah, it's fine because they've said
mean things about me because they say uh
yeah, I support the sovereignt massacre.
Um they can actually get sued for
copyright completely unjustly in a way
that will have negative impacts for
everyone else and kill criticism against
a completely reprehensible person.
>> That's such a morally
usually anti [__] I don't say tit this
is a standard guy.
>> I think we talk about Assan three times.
I think uh Dan [__] get summoned for
some reason.
>> Yeah.
>> [__]
>> Type [__]
The whole [__] combo with the guy was
the same was the same. Oh god for real
type [__] type [__]
>> Dan in the slime ball. Wait t one if you
like danceman. Two if you hate dance
woman.
>> This is a hard little chamber.
>> Hello people.
>> Okay, so we saw a bit of that dead ass.
like I'm like the only [__] northeast
coach to me talking about is proper was
to say first of all that that what
happening in the west bank is like camps
but
>> I think I don't think he's getting like
that he is getting swayed by them like
in some ways like I kind of understand
that it's shitty that a lot of but
actually you know what maybe it was
because that um
>> if he is then he's also getting then you
have to say he's also getting swayed by
all the DJers accusing him
>> wait okay okay I think it's about yeah
combats the the so-called uh
misogynistic
uh whatever the [__] it's called
misogynistic allegations I guess to buy
back caliphate so I think having a star
is on our side will be a good uh
combative reason I guess mercy
>> plus oh also have a I have a David the
Jewish guy
>> [__] good
>> seeard dirt that's another person who
couldn't be better she actually I
actually don't think she's capable of
being better than she is
>> yeah oh by the way ler are you actually
intending to watch that pisco versus
destiny debate because it's kind of a uh
>> okay it's kind I'm a waste of like it's
it Pisco is very pedantic. He loves to
do that ped and free [__]
>> This [__] throws like 30.
>> This person got blown out by Pisco by
the way.
>> 30 hypotheticals. But in like the the
whole conversation it's like four hours.
Okay. Let you know
>> it. It's not It doesn't stick to the
main topic of the conversation of the
whole Ethan Klein Denims case of Broen
arc conversation. I
>> No, it was it was about the court case.
>> Yeah. It transitions to the old you know
that [__]
And then yeah, it just [__] went
downhill. I'm not going to lie to you.
And then and then I think uh I think
midway through the conversation [__]
Piso was arguing Destiny and [__]
Destiny was going whole [__]
>> What side would you choose on? What side
would you choose? Our side or the J
side?
>> Oh, I mean yeah, maybe there was some of
that.
>> Yeah, but I mean like the fact that like
I think Destiny kind of like cuz I I did
watch that. I watched it off stream a
lot of it anyway. Um was like five
hours. Um, but
like I don't think it helps in the
slightest that Destiny was like is seems
to have been so quick to assume that
Pisco is only saying the things he does
because he's been influenced or like
captured by the the JT stockman
community. That doesn't make any sense
to me. Um, I think what maybe seems
probably to have influenced Pisco more,
if not just that he believes different
things, is also that um, as soon as he's
had any of these opinions that go
against the DG sphere, he gets attacked
probably by a larger number of Destiny
people.
>> Okay, this is totally reasonable. See,
we we we give we give ground where we
can. This is way more reasonable than
what he was saying about Pisco earlier.
This is absolutely, you know, totally
fair. Saying primarily just what he
actually believes, if he's been
influenced at all. It's probably
negative polarization from the fact that
he's been, you know, attacked for a tiny
[__] step out of line.
>> Like there's a few things that Peter
said that makes it sound like like very
first time. You know, when you're
talking about Ethan calling him a fake
lawyer in that one tweet and I saw the
tweet, it's like it's a pretty shitty
thing to say, but I'm like, okay, he
tweeted this once. Um, like dude, do you
have like I was like in my head I was
just thinking like do I really want to
do all wo is me and talk and compare
this to like what it's like with what I
get from son and like his community, you
know, like imagine if um
>> well
someone's not being sued in a box. So
what the [__] would that matter?
>> And the point being made there was just
does this fit the justification? If it
doesn't then you have to explain why.
You can't
cuz your justification is just oh they
lie. They lie sometimes.
They've said things that are wrong. They
think Zionist means ultraionist
genocidal lunatic and they say that
about Ethan and that's really mean.
That's the these are the [__]
arguments.
They suck. And you know they suck. You
must know they suck cuz you're not that
dumb.
>> Was like habitually calling Bisco a fake
lawyer and questioning his credentials
and being like quite sincere like with
like the Oh yeah, I don't know. Maybe we
should go and check if he actually um if
he passed the bar or not all because I I
just think this guy is like definitely
doing like a MP like a fraud style thing
and then like every time for example
like um Pisco's name comes up in any
Ethan orbiting sphere or Ethan friendly
sphere then all you see is like oh Pisco
fake lawyer check credential fraudster
piece of [__] [__] like hack lawyer
scam artist spiv and then maybe some
[__] memes get made out of like his
[__] personal life as well like that
would be more equivalent to what it's
like but in any case like I think the
the idea that he's just like getting
swayed by Jay soccer community is I
don't think it's
>> okay well that's literally what they do
in in DGG that that is literally what's
happening to so like you can draw this
super hard distinction between DG and
H3's community now but uh I'd like to
see that same attitude for bad empanada
and and community you know it's just
like [__] [__] the moment like
you they literally they can't analyze it
honestly and it's so shameful dude
is backed up that well.
>> Yeah,
>> I I agree. I don't think I don't think
he's getting like that he is getting
swayed by them. Like in some ways like I
kind of understand that it's shitty that
a lot of the Actually, you know what?
Maybe it was because that um
>> if he is then he's also getting then you
have to say he's also getting swayed by
all the DJers accusing him of being sued
and him also being like defiance against
them, right? So it's like Yeah.
>> Yeah. I don't think that I don't think
it's about like Pisco getting I don't
know like um I I think like it it is
weird.
>> Keep going down.
>> I don't know where the chat like the
like cuz like Yeah, I listen to that
conversation too and like Yeah. I feel
like Facebook's chat was kind of
unhinged like that from both sides.
There were like a couple of [__]
crazy.
>> You got to be in the room with the lava.
>> The room with the lava,
>> bro. With the lava.
>> You got to keep going down.
>> I got to keep going down.
>> Yep. You see on your map how it's got
that one little section. That's
>> I've been to the lava. Is this [__]
Yeah, but I've been to the bit with the
lava, haven't I? Did I go this way or
>> you never went fully down?
>> How do I go all the way down? Down here,
>> right?
>> Yeah. I know. I can see that you're at
the bridge, but you need to go away from
the bridge. go back up to where the
bench area is because the bench remember
you go down up and this
>> and this takes me to the
>> because it'll protect you doing two
damage while it's on cool down will only
do one if it's off cool down you're
[__]
>> so this flash game should have beat
expedition 33 in art direction by the
way
>> I [__] hold [__] [__] [__] the
company [__] the developers okay [__]
whoever wait is is spider spitting
is spider spit is this is this [__]
[__] spitting Listen, Spider, we
we understand that you did not like
Hollow Knight because you tried to play.
>> It's [__] ass. It's [__] dog [__]
>> And you and you were bad and that's why
that's that's why uh you uh that's
that's why you hate
>> How far did you get, Spider? [laughter]
>> Not really far. Like I did ask like it
was like the beginning of the game and I
was like, you know, let's just [__]
dog piss off.
>> Let me guess. You're a Marvel Rivals
player.
>> I am.
>> How many see how many hours I have? Like
what? How many hours I have?
>> Some people like different kinds of
games
like
Plus, not gonna lie, he should just like
ban the whole Destiny Ethan Klein drama
Discord.
>> He's kind of like his his server's kind
of like half and half. Sav J. Plus,
>> not going to lie, he should just like
ban the whole Destiny Ethan Klein drama
a while ago. He did. He Oh, yeah, he
did. He did that recently,
>> which he would not do if he was captured
by [__] Jtock and Creamman. So,
>> it seems like he actually doesn't want
anything to do with it.
>> Yeah, I think that that's I think I
don't think that's Yeah, I think that's
very silly. I do not think that Piso was
getting his I don't agree with that. I
think that's dumb. Like I mean I I don't
know why all those people decided to
show up in his chat. I don't know if
they're there all the time or if they're
only show up there when he's talking to
Destiny or about Destiny or about um uh
Ethan.
>> I don't know if Yeah, go ahead. You
probably know.
>> So yeah, because Pisco's Discord is
>> I literally I watch Pisco sometimes when
he's just covering politics and I see
chatters from here just in there when
he's covering politics. I see Bito in
there all the time. I see BTO. I see
from the southside. I see
um
I think I see Tequa in there sometimes.
>> Embedded with the uh the Taliban. Okay.
The Baliban law. Okay. Okay. And then um
peace goed with the uh
>> uh Jew stock Israel. Uh stalker Israel,
what the [__] it's called. All right.
>> So you got the you got the Christians.
You got the you got the Christians
versus the Muslims. Okay. Okay. Going at
it. Okay. You got Pisco Go. Okay. He's
like he's like the he's like the uh he's
like uh
the um he's like he's like
>> I only comment when Connor is on.
>> No, not the UN. Like the American Conor
tried to like make peace between those
two. [laughter]
>> We love Say he's like the British. It'd
be funnier.
>> Peaceful.
>> Yes. If you're trying to make an Israel
Palestine analogy. I will say, dude,
literally I've never like I thought
Connor's blatant sweeping was so bad.
I've literally never had a more positive
opinion of Connor than when I sat there
and watched uh Hutch react to the
Destiny debate like 30 minutes and then
switched over to Connor reacting to it
for 30 minutes. It was like night and
day, man. It was like It was crazy.
So, I've never heard Connor sound so
reasonable.
is like the British.
>> Yes, you're right. [cough]
Yeah, he's going to still nuke the [__]
because he had to like deal with it
later. You know what I'm saying? And
plus like his discord doesn't be like
the whole drama and [__] So
>> yeah, and him nuking it was like the
British saying we're out. I don't want
to.
>> It's not even that he was making sense.
It was more sense than Hutch.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah. I think that that I think that was
a good move on his part.
>> Um cuz Yeah. I don't like I mean I feel
bad for him too. Like he's gotten a lot
of [__] about like dumb bad things. He
just cares more about like talking about
Trump.
He got the he got the Ethan treatment.
I'm not going to hold you. Remember when
[__] Hassan and [__] his [__]
cooked [__] Pisco I mean not Pisco I
mean Ethan's comedian [__] Ethan
[__]
>> yeah basically. Yeah
>> kind of like kind of like plead for
sassan's discord cuz this remember
Hassan discord it's Hassan and Ethan
having a conversation. You can see
Hassan chat on the on the screen and
[__] Hassan chat Hassan's discord
server saying like all [__] about Ethan
Klein and Ethan Kle's like pleading for
[__] Hassan. Can you just like mark
your chat? and [__] house. I was
like,
>> uh, I don't know what to do, bro. Like,
>> he's [__] terrible, bro.
>> I'm a
>> You're being racist. I [laughter]
>> Holy [__] dude. What are you doing?
>> Yeah. Sorry.
>> Yeah. So, pretty much peace goes out the
[__] Ethan the Ethan trooper, bro.
So,
>> yeah, you're right. Yeah, he got he got
purity tested for not being anti-san
enough. I mean, like, yeah.
>> No, no, not not really. It's not really
the antihassan [__] that I really care
about. It's the more the it's the more
of the two communities.
>> There's a silk spool right back there
that you can use to recharge.
>> It's okay. I'm I'm reasonable health
now.
>> It was It was just the anti-assan [__]
It was more of the um [__] [__] uh
>> [__]
>> Yo, thank you for the ride, Aiden.
Welcome in. Welcome in.
>> [__] uh the Jedi versus the Sith.
[__] some [__] like with like
[__] peace coy
loyalty test on that [__] I believe the
Hassan [__]
>> This guy's so disabled, bro.
>> I don't know. I thought I thought it was
initially
>> I mean I mean it's fine. doesn't matter
that much
>> because the whole cuz the Hassan because
the whole Hassan show it's like it's a
little bit it's like whatever you can
just call you can call like peace go
[__] and just move on right at the end
of the day I mean compared to the whole
like um
the whole like [laughter]
Jes
>> yeah for DG I think it was the I think
their loyalty test there was like
>> [__] [__] [__]
like I think Destiny kind of like
because I I did watch that I watched it
off stream for a lot of it anyway
um was like 5 hours. Um but
>> have we gone back?
>> I don't think it helps in the slightest
that Destiny is was like is seems to
have been so quick to assume that
>> uh so it's like if you're floating down
I mean
>> well I'm just farming the last bit out
here. So
>> [__] give me a book on do some
research.
>> He always responds
>> it's going to take forever.
>> No, but like I'm just saying
>> I love Mau's quotes.
I think they massacred like [__] I am
John McCain
just like
>> uh a tricky old
>> Okay. Yeah, I think I think we've got
everything we can out of that. We get
all the good content out of that.
That's a lot that's a lone box segment.
Done.